τ ο πράμα ή επρινε καποιεθρποφασιστούν τε εργοννα γίνει πάση θυσία και πρέπι αγορωτον εργολάω
πρέπει να λίου πρβλήματα πρέπει να περάσω τουν το πράγμα τον εμν κάει έτσια δήμαρχος
ο ποίος ούληήμερα καλούν τουν πράβο και ενα έχει τσιπργματα δήμαρχος οποίος ενα χιτούτε αντιδράσεις
δεν προχωρά προστά τια κλείρα μάρτια του και αύν κύρίγος ταμάχι του εν κνο διντο
αραθερω ότι εγκάλι το οποίο κι ανέργον το οποίο ξέριατί να γίν να τόσα χρόνια
κκάτι θα θέλ να κννοπρ καθέ θελα να περάσειτεά τακριώ τοόταν όταν όταν ερώτησα των
προϊδημοτικών μηχανικών του δγήμου πα πολύ καλοφύρς και πολύ γαλο σην εργά τη αντραδο το
το έργο οεπίρε κι κάμετ τιαρμηνικής εκλησίας ε επίδαςκαι κμε τους παράδρομους τούτους δρόμους τους
κύριους δντλο και τους έκαμαμε τόσν κρονανμου ίμαρχε ν και θέ κανε νανα αλάβει τυν
την κουμέντα εκχε καεναλέει ποιος ποιος έθελε να πλέξι μέστον των κυκαίονα σε μια δο
σείνι λικρίνια γι αυτό βρίσκαμε άλλα εργα να κάμνουμε κάποιος πρέπει να αναλάβει τουν την
ευθύνη θέρα από ότι έξερατο ότι γιτ να περάσουμε τουν τα πράγματα ενώ θέλω απω
ότι πρέπει να εμαστε αμέ να βοηθούμε τον κόσμο να ποιέζζουμε των εργολάβων νν ευκολά
πράγματα ενα χιεργν εύκολον έχιέργοπου πάει όπως τα παραμήθια ενέργο τα οποία θέλου συμπιγμή θέλουν
ποίες ή θέλουν ση νανα εξασκείι τις δρήτρες του συμβολέου αλλά ένα έργο τ ποίων
να τηλιώσει και πρέπει να τεοιώσει γιατί ο φίλουμετο στην πολη και φίλουμενο και στους
ανθρώπους που επενδήσαν τις δωές του κιμ τα καταστήματα δμάρχος λάνα πως βλέ τα συχνά
επισόδια αποκαταγράφοντα στην πόλη μετάξει άλλοδάπο ατα σοβαράμε έλο απω ότι πράβαλούμε να πραγμάοτε στο
στην τους διαστασινομος ότι εκαι σ πολύντού της τιγμή στην ευρώπηνόή στην κύπρον που ένχει
θέματα πουμεμετα μένααστευτικώ ενί ζητήματα τα ια πρέπα πιληθούσει και ούτε πρέπει να να λέμε
ότι ενούλι μετανάστεη γιατί θέλα πό ότι τα προβλήα να προγαλήταμε τα μικρή μιερίρα και
πάι κι θύμ